So yesterday afternoon comes on the East
Coast. Very abruptly scheduled press conference
was scheduled with Donald Trump's press secretary,
Kayleigh McEnany, RNC chair woman Ronna McDaniel,
and some lawyer. Now, you might ask, is it
appropriate for the White House press secretary to
be doing this? Fearnot Kayleigh McEnany opened
the press conference by saying, I'm Kayleigh
McEnany and I'm here in my personal capacity.
She's not there as White House press secretary,
which just continues to be completely hilarious.
But there's just too much going on to even focus
on that. So Caylee is asked during this press
conference, do you have evidence of even a single
illegal vote being cast? And she doesn't. She
says a lot of stuff, but she doesn't take a look.
Sounds like, you know, the
primary votes were actually
cast for her. You simply say we don't know.
What we are asking for here is patience, Ron. And
just mentioned to you the more than I believe was
one hundred thirty affidavits in Michigan alone.
We're aware of all the reports of thousands
of votes in Nevada that were cast by those who
are not eligible. We're hearing these reports.
We're seeing them come in. We are vetting them.
We are getting affidavits. So right now,
we would point you to all of that. That
information is publicly available. But what we're
asking for right now is patience as we explore
these equal protection claims, among others.
So as you can see the answer to do you have
evidence of a single illegal or fraudulent
vote for now is no, they don't actually have
evidence of that. But then this is just the great
part. This aired during a Fox News Neil Cavuto
show. Cavuto actually interrupts this nonsense. He
says, whoa, whoa, whoa, we can't air this, these
are very serious allegations that are completely
unproven. And what I'm not going to defend Fox
News or Neil Cavuto in any general sense. But
what I like about this clip we're going to see
is that Neil Cavuto is putting a name
to the fact that these are outrageous
allegations. These are allegations that
call into question at the most basic level,
whether voting even works in this country.
And Neil Cavuto points out, hey, you know,
we can't normalize these claims when Trump comes
out and says it was all stolen and I'm going to
get Georgia and I'm going to get Wisconsin. And
he said Nevada and Pennsylvania, these are wildly
serious allegations that are unproven and we can't
air it is what Neil Cavuto said, illegal votes.
Well, I just think we have to be very clear
that she's charging. The other side is
welcoming fraud and welcoming illegal voting
unless she has more details to back that up.
I can't in good countenance continue showing you
this. I want to make sure that maybe they do have
something to back that up. But that's an explosive
charge to make. The other side is effectively
rigging and cheating. If she does bring proof
of that, of course, we'll take you back.
So far, she started saying right at the outset,
welcoming fraud, welcoming illegal voting.
Not so fast. We'll have more after this.
So this really is amazing and to be clear,
you know, this is not that Fox News is great or
trustworthy. Fox News is insanely untrustworthy.
Even some of their anchors, though, are saying
we can't air this in good conscience at night
during primetime. When you get to Hannity and
Tucker and Laura Ingraham, I don't know about
Jeanine Pirro. She might be suspended right now.
They are going full bore into it was stolen.
But at least here, Neil Cavuto says no
dice. And hilariously, all sorts of Fox
viewers started immediately tweeting Neil
Cavuto must be fired because he did this. So
let's not think for a second that Fox News is now
respectable. They're still allowing Hannity and
Carlson and Ingram to do their screeching screeds
every single night. But what's great about this is
that it has completely triggered the Trump being
right. And this will lead into the story we'll
do after my conversation today with Peter Joseph,
which is that Trump now is furious with Fox News
and he has been relegated to tweeting clips of
Newsmax. If you can imagine, he's mad at Fox.
He needs to be. There's got to be somebody that
continues to say that it's all been stolen even
during the so-called news portions. And he found
it at Newsmax. Will look at clips of that later
on. Make sure you're following the show on
Instagram at David Pakman show. Follow me on
Instagram at David Pakman for evidence. We've
gotten some really strong read tweets lately
from some really great people. A Colin Hanks,
the son of Tom Hanks, is now following the show
and has been amplifying some of our
material. Superstar actress Gabrielle Union
retweeting some of our stuff.
Really, really great. And we
appreciate it so much. Follow me at David
Pakman on Instagram to see some of that.
We'll take a quick break and be back after
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot com.